as we were saying these are the first
public hearings and the two witnesses
that we heard from they're the two
senior diplomats William Taylor and
George Kent went before the committee in
the closed-door session last month and
essentially what we what we heard from
them was more of the same what they what
they gave in that closed-door session
and there is a fair degree of political
theater to some of this isn't there in
the fact that this is this is playing
out before the public now did you hear
anything new and what were your overall
impressions of this so far I think the
most important thing we heard were these
two witnesses explaining why the Ukraine
is so important to American interests
and how the president's alleged actions
worked against American interest in
American national security there have
been a lot of allegations about the
president's behavior a lot of discussion
about about how those may have played
out and the personalities involved but
negotiating this impeachment process
involves a judgement about whether the
president's actions constitute an abuse
of power that would justify potentially
removing him from office and these two
witnesses statements about the
importance of Ukraine to American
security and how the president's
irregular informal diplomacy to advance
his own election interests may have hurt
their security was I think an important
new addition to the public discussion
about about impeachment I want to ask
you as well in particular about William
Taylor the the US ambassador to Ukraine
who who we heard a lot more from it's
fair to say what did you make of his
overall demeanor and his his credibility
as as a witness when he spoke I think
it's a stark contrast to all of the
other public discussion most of the
debate has been carried out by people
who come off as extremely partisan
supporters of the President opponents of
the president and here finally in public
for the first time we see the career
diplomats and and public servants who
have been tasked with representing the
United States abroad telling their
version of events sort of a third take
on this from from a neutral point of
view and then that again is another
important new element of the impeachment
process we're hearing for the first time
one of the things that struck me was
something that William Taylor said in in
that testimony and I wanted to ask you
about this what do you what did you make
of the fact that this is a current US
ambassador making it very clear that the
president's attitude towards another
country was in his words illogical could
not be explained and was crazy what did
you make of that I mean those are
stunning things for a sitting ambassador
acting ambassador to say about the u.s.
president or any ambassador to say about
the head of state of his own country and
the fact that this experienced public
servant can attach no logical
explanation to the president's actions
other than the president's narrow
political self-interest is pretty
startling all right for the moment
Joseph thanks very much there'll be lots
more to chew on on this no doubt but for
the moment thanks very much let's go to
Kimberly how keen now a White House
correspondent who is standing by there
so Kimberly we know that at least that's
what we've been told that President
Trump did not watch any of this but what
are they likely to be saying about this
well I suspect the president did watch
because throughout this there was some
tweeting and retweeting that was taking
place mostly of arguments favorable to
the president and we did have a
statement also from the press secretary
Stephane Grisham on social media she
says that this hearing is a sham hearing
it's boring and a colossal waste of
taxpayer time so it does appear that the
White House at least staff if not the
president is watching this very
carefully because some of the testimony
that has been presented thus far well it
might be boring is particularly damning
if you drill down deep into what the
case is being made is that there were
two channels of foreign policy with
respect to Ukraine let's take a listen
to the opening statements of both of
these career officials who
have served they note under multiple
presidents both Democrat and Republican
as a general principle I do not believe
the United States should ask other
countries to engage in selective
politically associated investigations or
prosecutions against opponents of those
in power because such selective actions
undermine the rule of law regardless of
the country in a regular NSC secure
video conference call in July 18th I
heard a staff person from the Office of
Management and Budget say that there was
a hold on security assistance to Ukraine
but could not say why toward the end of
an otherwise normal meeting a voice on
the call the person was off-screen said
that she was from OMB and her boss had
instructed her not to approve any
additional spending on security systems
for Ukraine until further notice I and
others set in astonishment Ukrainians
were fighting Russians and counted on
not only the training and weapons but
also the assurance of US support all
that the OMB staff person said was that
the directive had come from the
president to the chief of staff to OMB
yeah as you say can't believe some
pretty damning testimony there from two
people who are career officials career
diplomats and while we're waiting for
this recess to end and the hearings to
to pick up we are going to that the
Republicans are going to give their
opportunity to essentially cross-examine
both of these two witnesses and
presumably that's something that the the
White House is is going to be very
eagerly awaiting yeah because
particularly given the fact that
Republicans up to now have argued that
this has not been a fair process that
this has not been objective in any way
that up until now until these public
hearings this has been held in secret
they argue and we saw this at the
beginning of these proceedings where a
number of Republicans proceeded to sort
of interrupt the process bring two-point
parliamentary order with questions
regarding whether they would have the
opportunity to call witnesses that they
are important well the Republicans will
be able to do cross-examination what
they haven't been able to do and what
they tried to get there at the beginning
on public record was the fact that they
want to call a number of witnesses that
they say Democrats have pushed back on
number one the whistle blower the
individual who didn't hear that July
25th phone call between the US president
and the Ukrainian president but in fact
heard of it from others was deeply
concerned reported it to the
intelligence committees Inspector
General that is what really launched
this impeachment proceeding the other
witness that the Republicans are very
keen to call is hunter Biden the son of
the former Vice President Joe Biden and
when you hear them talking about
Purisima of course that being the energy
company that is the focus of hunter
Biden serving on that board the members
of the Republican Party they say that
they want to dive down deep that they
say these are legitimate questions that
need to be explored that whether or not
there was any corruption under the vice
president while he was son was serving
so well these have been pushed back on
by Democrats what we expect to hear more
of as Republicans get the opportunity to
question is these lines and these
arguments that they hope if not
successful in swaying the Democrats that
will be ultimately voting we believe to
impeach the president the end of these
proceedings may sway public opinion
because right now we know according to
polls that it's just a narrow majority
of Americans that support impeaching the
president on this issue and of course
Democrats are hoping to make that a
large majority their works cut out for
them given the fact that much of this is
very confusing it's very legal it's very
deep in the weeds and there's also this
challenge to that these are sort of the
Washington insiders that Donald Trump
campaigned against that he said he
wanted to drain the swamp that he these
are the people that control the power so
there are a number of narratives that
are sort of percolating underneath here
that are going to be a challenge for the
Democrats to put forward to make their
case yeah one of the things that we
heard a lot of from from both of these
witnesses was
the influence of rudy guiliani the
president's personal lawyer and his
involvement in all of this and the
perception that he was essentially
engaging in in a separate u.s. foreign
policy they talked about a regular
channel and an irregular Channel yeah it
wasn't just said once it was said
multiple times and this is the problem
for this White House that he the
ambassador Taylor used words like
alarmed that there were two channels it
was irregular it was crazy
essentially underscoring that there was
one channel for foreign policy with
respect to Ukraine that was the typical
diplomatic State Department Channel and
the other one that was operating under
the trump administration headed up by
the president's personal lawyer Rudolph
Giuliani
all right Kimberly for the moment thanks
very much Kimberly halket outside the
White House force let's go back to
Joseph or associate professor of
political science at Texas A&M
University in the cutter joining us here
from Doha so I want to ask you then
about Rudy Giuliani what do you make of
the fact that you know he was he was
mentioned quite prominently in that
testimony the White House personal
lawyer and what what they saw as his
kind of unseemly involvement in the
whole u.s. relationship with Ukraine I
mean it's certainly not unusual for
presidents to use personal contacts
outside of the normal channels to try to
reinforce official foreign policy what's
unusual in this case is mr. Taylor's
testimony that the irregular informal
channels of mr. Trump's communication
with the Ukrainian government flowing
through mr. Giuliani seemed to be at
odds with the official u.s. foreign
policy and its commitments to Ukrainian
security and contrary to Russian
aggression in in Ukraine
how much could all of this then come
down to public opinion essentially I
mean killed Kimberly made mention of
that earlier that opinions are very
hardened on both sides this whole
process has been seen to be very
partisan not a single Republican vote
to go ahead with the impeachment
investigation do you expect anything
that we've heard so far or the perhaps
we will hear later today that might move
the needle in any way any direction it's
hard to say but of course the the thing
that really struck me was the impartial
tone of these two witnesses it really
did just stand in a very stark contrast
to the way that many Democrats in
Congress have talked about impeachment
certainly the way the Republicans have
talked about impeachment and defended
the president that here are these two
public service servants a career
diplomat a man who's been in in the
military and served the United States in
a variety of capacities for for
president stretching back to Ronald
Reagan talking about how the president's
attempts to influence relations with the
Ukraine were deeply at odds with
national security and contrary to
through all traditional patterns of
American diplomacy it's hard to think
that that won't be convincing to anyone
who is approaching this with an open
mind no matter how modest a slice of the
public that may be at this point
so when these hearings resume and we
maybe see some indications of that right
now the Republicans will as I said get
their opportunity to question these two
witnesses they'll get 45 minutes just
like the Democrats got 45 minutes what
it what do you expect them to do as they
attempt to that's discredit these
witnesses congressman Nunez opening
statement I think is a template they'll
raise a variety of allegations about
Ukrainian involvement in the 2016
election about the sort of Mullah report
and whether or not that indicated the
president Trump had colluded with the
Russian government during the campaign
and essentially just repeat over and
over again the names and then sort of
tag lines of these various scandals
probably in an effort to lump these new
allegations in with with the kind of
mass of scandals that have
sort of overwhelmed American politics in
the last few years